gerroff on c is attached to the bit of
chestnut forest he owns a fees on that
would his ancestors are all buried here
in near the village of p 0 vector and
this is where he wants to spend his old
age it could all be so wonderful if it
weren't for the animals goats cows and
even pigs wander freely through a
fancies garden discret is on simpleton
novel in the old days they built walls
here to protect the trees this is where
the wall was but the pigs have rooted
around here destroying the wall and
digging up the roots of the tree e me as
now the roots are exposed dude album
Caleb the former Forester belongs to a
group of retirees who have returned to
peel betta their home village on Corsica
after living elsewhere for decades well
they were away they say local farmers
simply took over their gardens the
farmers want grazing land for their
animals and EU subsidies to please head
over the more animals a farmer has the
greater the subsidies he gets and to
maintain the animals he needs land for
grazing hey Dan normal dicta yeah I know
copy this is our land the farmer simply
tell the EU we have a few Hector's here
and we own a few Hector's there this is
our property this is so no pop dat
goatherd ang pow alphonse e has lived in
feel betta for more than 40 years he
can't imagine fencing in his goats as
far back as he can remember domestic
animals have always been free to wander
in PA betta seagull door that's good for
them to get out we can eat the weeds and
move about freely the pensioners want
the court to enforce their rights
they've already got a judgment against
the village that says it should provide
this fenced-in meadow for the animals
but how can the retirees make the
animals go there the mayor refuses to
use the police the pensioners say he's
on the farmers side OB AV predominately
don't go rear if you turn this water
faucet on nothing happens let's follow
the hose yeah well see this is the hose
that's meant to bring the water the
retirees court records fill a whole
cabinet in the Town Hall the legal
battle has cost the town thousands of
euros the mayor hasn't been able to
solve the problem he says the retirees
who have returned here just want to
dominate vo vechta said Aquino we are
using for you it's not true what they
say there's nothing to ruin on their
property they dont cultivate anything
they spent years pursuing their careers
on the mainland and now they're all
upset about a few trees they never took
care of anyway for the last 60 years
vanellope a date with the mayor showing
so little understanding jarrar alfonsi
feels entitled to resort to drastic
measures when animals wander onto his
property he shoots them he's been doing
that for years you should wish again it
must have been about 40 pigs and also
about a dozen cows there were a few
bulls to you when Paul Alphonse he hears
of this he calls it brutality and says
at some point the farmers will have to
defend themselves the loss of their
livestock cost them a lot of money
really who interfere it breaks my heart
to slaughter a goat and these people
shooter Danimals is if they were
cardboard targets the pensioners are
calling for a law and order they want
every cow goat and pig behind a fence
what they apparently haven't considered
is that free-range farm animals have
long been part of pio bettas charm
you